[Applause]
originally I want just to read my speech
from the smartphone but a few days ago
one of the winner director took a photo
of mine of me that I was playing with my
smartphone and also he asked me to sign
for it
so I decided to not do that I feel so
excited and happy to accept this award
and what's more I learned that this is
the first time that this kind of owner
goes to China Thank You Academy of Fine
Arts are really really a proud
[Applause]
I want to share leatherby the story a
shorter story about myself when the
first time I start to learn the drawer
my father was my model and for let me
have a better observation and help me in
the drawing process he always holds his
pose as long at it it's possible
sometimes the drawing process lasts to
one hour so he will show some discomfort
from his face I were talking that you
can move your body you can feel relaxed
but he just frees himself for me and
I'll truly learn drawing so quickly
through this way I tell you this story
because I think there are a lot of
people which support me through this
year part of they're not here but they
all made it possible for me stand here
so I want to say thank you to my parents
my family
China Thank You Academy of Fine Arts my
teachers classmates friends thank you
off then just made it possible thank you
and also definitely the Academy thank
you thank you changing the rules and
thank you thank you holding events thank
you thank you so much
[Applause]